hey guys what's up it's Ryan right over
here we're gonna be checking out the
trailer today for masterminds Zach
Galifianakis Kristen Wiig sounds like an
awesome combo duo partner seventeen
million dollars or these have no leads
after the identity of these criminal
masterminds let's do it robbing a teen
camp for at-risk
Oh No wait just hold on right here
don't worry about
ouch that movie does look really funny
it's been a while since I've seen a
comedy trailer that really made me laugh
that looks great I love the cast
assembled Zach Galifianakis [ __ ]
hilarious
I've been following him since he was
doing stand-up one of the best comedians
out there right now
I love seeing him when he does like more
of a character Ben and Kristen Wiig are
bouncing off each other well Kristen
Wiig one of the funniest woman alive
right now
and you got Jason Sudeikis I actually
just caught Horrible Bosses 2 I know I
didn't get the greatest reviews but I
think for a DVD movie I thought it was
really funny and I thought Jason
Sudeikis was hilarious in it and Owen
Wilson I [ __ ] love Owen Wilson
I watched Shanghai noon like a month ago
and I forgot just how much I love Owen
Wilson and almost everything he does and
he's doing that other movie with Pierce
Brosnan where he's really intense and
serious and he was an inherent vice it's
awesome to watch him do more character
roles now yeah I'm so on board for this
the fact that it's a comedy based on a
true story
it looks like it's executed in a very
fun way could be a little dark the
trailer doesn't really show that but I
get the sense of there'll be some
darkness you know it kind of makes me
think like there was pain and gain which
was a dark comedy based on a true story
and it didn't fly too well with a lot of
people they were like usually guys are
criminals and these guys similar thing
it's like these guys are criminals as
well and it's based on a true story but
it looks like this is like [ __ ]
hilarious
it's much more over-the-top I think than
painting Jane was yeah that movie looks
[ __ ] funny can't wait to check it out
if you guys are new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects please
do so we need this a subscriber spot for
Bart I'm tallying in Spanish at the same
time you can follow us on Facebook
Instagram and Twitter
why not I'm feeling good from that
trailer let's do a shout out
Eric green hi Ryan
the real rejects are my favorite channel
in case my English has some faults it's
because I am from Sweden because you're
Swedish I'm going to assume that you
really like your coffee that shopping is
[ __ ] insane with you and that you're
very outdoorsy and that businesses will
shut down a lot around your awesome
country Swedish people though they're
very I'm not gonna lie I don't know [ __ ]
about Swedish people I don't even know
what you guys look like